viejo tel soviéticos como un microcosmos
de la gran e actual mujeres niños y
mayores cargados de maletas que han
huido a las regiones del este y centro
del país han encontrado aquí un lugar
seguro desde el inicio de la segunda
fase la invasión rusa la región de
dmitro ha recibido a más de 55 mil
desplazados y
vamos a estar aquí un tiempo confiamos
en que la situación mejore y podamos
regresar pronto a grama torch queremos
vivir en paz como lo hacíamos antes
último sonido los pasillos se han
convertido en improvisados parques
infantiles para estos niños refugiados
bajo la supervisión de veteranas
cuidadoras dentro de cada habitación se
guardan historias íntimas de familias
divididas por la guerra como alexandra
cousteau
pienso mucho en mi mujer y mi hijo ellos
están a salvo en la república checa
ojalá la guerra termine pronto y pueda
reunirme con ellos
dinero es por ahora la más segura de las
regiones del este de ucrania aún así el
gobierno local no puede bajar la guardia
porque en cualquier momento puede
convertirse en objetivo y
estamos preparados para recibir a más
desplazados y coordinar la evacuación
les damos refugio medicinas acceso
hospital y 14.000 niños están recibiendo
educación online
martín un misionero mexicano y su grupo
de voluntarios ayudan a los desplazados
a combatir el frío con sopa caliente
antes de emprender el viaje
somos de tomar a la gente que está
saliendo de viaje hacer la frontera
entonces ustedes en la estación de
trenes famosa aquí ando de comer y vamos
a repartir comida la estación de tren de
dmitro es la última esperanza para los
desplazados del este de ucrania que han
decidido ir del país ante el temor de
quedarse asediados por las tropas rusas